so i'm a huge admirer of yours in large
part because your origin story so i just
wanted to
to geek out a little bit um because you
and i have a lot in common i don't know
how if you know how much we have in
common so check it out
i'm the the child of taiwanese american
immigrants
my dad had a phd in physics
my mom had a master's in math they came
here there was this period in the 60s
when the u.s was letting in
taiwanese grad students and so they came
here they met each other
and they had me and my brother in the
70s
i think you and i might even have been
born the same year
and then i went to phillips exeter
and graduated in 92
and then i wound up going to uh columbia
for law school where you went undergrad
um so the thing that blows my mind about
you i jen
is that you and i i think you know have
those things in common i think pretty
much everything i just stated um
like it could have been you talking but
then but then you did something that was
so unusual certainly for our community
really for anyone because you know
there aren't many people like you um so
you
have this education that primes you for
doing frankly you know like what a lot
of our peers did out of a place like
columbia which would be
medicine finance consulting business
tech in my case law and the rest of it
but then you
took a very very sharp detour and became
a labor
organizer so i would love to hear how
the heck that happened
wow i had no idea we had that many
experiences in common that's incredible
um
thank you for naming all of that we have
lots to talk about
but in terms of how i became a labor
organizer
when i was in college at columbia i one
of the reasons why i wanted to go to
columbia was it was in new york city
and the city and its energy
and its diversity in communities and the
size of the asian immigrant community
and new york were some of the reasons
why i wanted to be there and
i started volunteering at a domestic
violence shelter for asian immigrant
women
and i could still speak mandarin so i
was actually of value in terms of being
a bilingual hotline volunteer
and and a lot of the calls
were not just about the struggles of
surviving violence
or abuse but a lot of them were about
how hard it was to just survive as a mom
as someone working in a low-wage service
job
you know i would hear from women who
were domestic violence survivors who
were working in
nail salons are doing domestic work and
long long hours and still not able to
pay the rent or you know cover the
expenses related to school
for kids and i just remember thinking
like how could it be that there's so
many people who work so hard
and do everything right and survive
so much and still can't make a decent
living and take care of the people they
love
and that kind of led me down a path of
trying to figure out how we make
work better for women especially women
in our communities women of color
women who are really struggling at the
bottom of the economy where
we just don't value so much work that's
actually essential
there are a lot of people who frankly
volunteer at nonprofits when they're in
college
um but then they don't make a career out
of it in the same way that you have so
like
the thing that again i just want because
i'm genuinely curious i think you can
tell
is so you're an undergrad you're
volunteering
downtown um and then like how are you
spending your summers like
and what is your first job when you
graduate from school and also like how
is your family taking this in but i'd
love to start really like with
what your college career looked like and
then what what your first job was
yeah so in college i volunteered
at the new york asian women's shelter
and then also at the committee against
anti-asian violence as you mentioned
where we started the women workers
project
that led to lots of the other work to
organize domestic workers
and then i also on campus was involved
in
a campaign in 1996 to win
ethnic studies on campus at columbia so
in the spring of 1996 there was kind of
a multiracial coalition of students who
came together
to fight for an ethnic studies
department and
the combination of the volunteering on
campus
or the volunteering outside of campus in
the community
and the work to try to change how things
worked
on campus and working across race
it was really transformative to me like
i the fact that we actually waged a
campaign
we took over buildings we went on hunger
strike we did all kinds of stuff
and we won there's now a center for the
study of ethnicity and race
at columbia because of the activism that
we did and i think i got kind of
addicted to
winning like i just got really
excited about the fact that you're like
one for one what else could i do
yeah i kind of was like hey you could
get just like regular people together
get together and fight for something and
make some real
change that can affect future
generations and i
think i kind of caught the bug but i
didn't know that you could make it a
career to be honest andrew
yeah exactly yeah no there was no i did
not think of it as a career i
thought maybe i would be a writer
i was tutoring at the borough of
manhattan community college
as a you know in the summers and then
after i graduated
to help people prepare for the writing
assessment test
um i thought i would like get some kind
of a job to pay the bills while i wrote
um
sure maybe publishing or something like
that yeah exactly yeah i also worked in
restaurants i was
waited tables and i worked as a
bartender
like how did you figure out that
activism was an actual career choice
after you'd had this massive victory or
senior spring
i didn't really know that it was um we
at when i was working when i was
volunteering at cav
and we started the women workers project
the committee against anti-asian
violence
we started the women workers project as
kind of an all-volunteer committee
to do outreach to women working in
different low-wage service jobs and
to try to organize for better conditions
and
we were all volunteer and then
we realized that we needed somebody
full-time
who would get up every day and really be
thinking about how to move this work
forward
and follow through and keep in touch
with the workers we were meeting
and and we put together a job
description we applied for
some grant money to fund the position
and i really didn't think that i would
do that but when
nobody applied for the job everyone in
the volunteer committee convinced me to
do it
so i started out doing it part time for
a while and then it became full time and
i think what i'll say is that even then
i didn't think of it as my life's path i
just kind of
i think i followed the women that
i met and organized with along the way
and
was so moved by the incredible courage
and resilience of
the women that i would meet in the work
and i just kind of took their lead and
kept going and um and
we would win along the way and that also
kept me going
wow so you're kind of you're tutoring
your
bartending and then you're volunteering
and then the volunteerism gets to a
point like hey someone should
actually start doing this uh like part
time so do you remember
who the original grantors were to fund
the this part-time and then full-time
position
i think the new york women's foundation
and
the ms foundation may be
the north star was a while ago obviously
yeah some
some of the grassroots social justice
foundations in new york city
really important early supporters for
seed projects like that
so listen to this philanthropist and
funders
you end up funding these uh these
positions and then sometimes they end up
mushrooming into these world-changing
activists
doesn't happen you know if you don't
fund it who knows maybe igen is
uh is doing something else right now
you never know so philanthropists you
gotta get in there early
uh so you're working um
eventually a full-time role um for cav
and then you wound up transitioning into
uh starting your own um or organizing
really domestic workers and starting an
organization to that effect
um what is that arc like because i you
know i can see the volunteer i can see
okay
no one else wants to do it so everyone's
like hi jen you do it and one of the
things that happens in these
environments
it's a little bit like a school project
where responsibility ends up falling on
whoever the most competent
person is you know what i mean like like
if you have like a class project and
there are five of you and then there's
one person who's on top of it and the
other four
you know not as good so that everyone's
like
ooh person who's on top of it that's
like so i can i can imagine that
happening and i can imagine
um you know you're doing it full-time
but then there was like this entire arc
where you go from
part-time to full-time to actually
starting your own organization which is
a very very big deal
um and this i i'd imagine happened this
arc
transpired it seems like throughout your
20s
well one thing that your listeners
should really know is that none of these
things
are because of singular individuals
or processes and at least in my
experience
i've been organizing for 25 years and
it has always been a collective effort
and maybe my name is
on paper as the staff person or as the
executive director
as a co-founder but it takes
groups of us squads it's always a squad
effort i find
and i'm sure you found this too with
your campaign andrews like
it took like there was just like an
essential core
group every time to really take the work
to the next level
and and that's really i think the story
of the domestic workers movement that
i've been a part of has been
it was like a group of filipino domestic
workers who decide to take the project
multiracial
and then a group of caribbean women who
decide to
really expand strengthen the work in new
york city
together with filipinas and south asian
women
and latina workers and then
a group of new york workers then get
together with a group of workers from
la dc seattle san francisco
and then we launched the national
alliance we had 50 co-founders of the
national alliance
in 2007 and then a group of us
you know in the domestic workers
movement after the 2016 elections
you know a bunch of domestic workers
said we need an
advocacy platform we have to be able to
use
every tool at our disposal to make this
democracy
to save our democracy and to make it
work for us
and so that's how care and action was
formed and it was never
ever me i i'm often the fundraiser
to be honest
but there's so much leadership and so
much collective leadership behind
every effort and every breakthrough and
and so many of the people who made this
moment
in the movement possible they're names
that you'll never hear of but
who were absolutely essential to the
work
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you